WHEN DONALD TRUMP GETS
REELECTED, WE WILL HAVE TANGIBLE
EVIDENCE SHOWING EXACTLY HOW IT
HAPPEN.
THE OTHER SOMBER AND SERIOUS
PERSON'S HOUSE JUDICIARY
CHAIRMAN JERRY NADLER WHO
ACTUALLY FELL ASLEEP YESTERDAY
DURING THE HEARING HE WAS
SUPPOSEDLY OVERSEEING, WATCH
THIS.
>> THERE IS NO DOUBT IT WILL BE
AN UNFAIR AND PARTISAN EFFORT.
THIS ON THE AMERICAN PEOPLE
DESERVE BETTER.
DEMOCRATS ON THIS COMMITTEE
DON'T LIKE THIS PRESIDENT, THEY
DON'T LIKE HIS POLICIES, THEY
DON'T LIKE HIM AS A PERSON, THEY
DON'T LIKE THE FACT THAT THE
INVESTIGATION WAS A FLOP SO NOW
YOU'RE GOING TO IMPEACH HIM.
>> Tucker: HARD TO JUDGE THAT
MANY PEOPLE FELT THAT WAY, SHE
HOSTS JUST AS WITH JANINE WE ARE
ALWAYS GRATEFUL TO HAVE HER ON
THE SHOW.
SO IS IT JUST WISHFUL THINKING
OR IS IT TRUE WHEN IT SEEMS LIKE
TO ME THAT THIS HAS THE CAPACITY
TO BOOMERANG AND REALLY HURT THE
PEOPLE STAGING THE SHOW?
>> OF COURSE, EVERYONE IS
ASSUMING IT'S GOING TO BOOMERANG
AND HURT THEM BUT THE PROOF IS
IN THE FACT THAT THEY HAVE THIS
RUSH TO JUDGMENT, THE DEMOCRATS
NOW.
WHY ARE THEY RUSHING?
WHY ARE THEY NOT WAITING FOR THE
MATERIAL WITNESS IS THAT THEY
MIGHT BE ABLE TO BRING ON TO
GIVE MORE INSIGHT AND MORE FACTS
BECAUSE IF YOU WILL REMEMBER THE
SO-CALLED EVIDENCE THAT THEY
SHOWED US, NONE OF THOSE
WITNESSES AND THE INTELLIGENCE
COMMITTEE HAD ANY EVIDENCE ABOUT
A QUID PRO QUO, NONE OF THE
PROFESSORS KNEW ANY OF THE
FACTS, SO WHAT WE HAVE ARE JUST
A BUNCH OF PEOPLE WHO HATE
DONALD TRUMP AND YET THE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE SOME INFORMATION ABOUT
THIS LIKE JOHN BOLTON, LIKE
MICK MULVANEY, THEY DON'T EVEN
WANT TO WAIT FOR THEM.
OF WHY?
THEY ARE LOSING THEIR IMPETUS
NOW.
THE AMERICAN PUBLIC AND STARTING
TO GET TIRED OF THIS.
MAKES NO SENSE.
THERE IS NO SMOKING GUN.
SO NOW NANCY PELOSI IS LIKE
LET'S GET THIS DONE, LET'S GET
THIS DONE RIGHT AWAY.
I HOPE THEY GET IT DONE RIGHT
AWAY AND I HOPE THEY START A
TRIAL IN THE SENATE AND THEY PUT
ON NANCY PELOSI AND ADAM SCHIFF
AND JOE BIDEN AND HUNTER BIDEN
AND ALL OF THE PLAYERS.
YOU WANT TO SHOW, LET'S PUT ON A
SHOW BUT HERE'S THE PROBLEM.
IS MY WHEELHOUSE A LITTLE BIT.
THE BOTTOM LINE IS THERE IS NO
EVIDENCE.
YOU HAVE A BUNCH OF TRUMP HATING
PEOPLE WITH THIS FEMALE
PROFESSOR GOING AFTER
BARRON TRUMP AND PEOPLE COULDN'T
PASS AN ENGLISH COURSE WHO SAY
THAT WHEN THE PRESIDENT SAYS
U.S. A FAVOR BECAUSE OUR COUNTRY
HAS BEEN THROUGH A LOT, HE IS
REALLY SAYING DOING THE KING A
FAVOR.
>> Tucker: I ALMOST FEEL
GUILTY HIGHLIGHTING THE STEPS, A
LOT OF THE CABLE NETWORKS ARE
ABETTING THIS RIDICULOUS
SIDESHOW.
BUT I DID SAY ONE THING TODAY I
WANTED TO ASK YOU ABOUT MY ONE
OF THE NUGGETS THAT I THINK IS
SIGNIFICANT IS THE FACT THAT
ADAM SCHIFF'S COMMITTEE SOMEHOW
WOUND UP WITH THE PHONE RECORDS
OF THE PRESIDENT'S LAWYER.
SO THE CONGRESSMAN FROM TODAY
SUGGESTED THE REPUBLICAN'S
SUBPOENA ADAM SCHIFF'S PHONE
RECORDS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK OF THAT?
>> I THINK IT'S ONLY FAIR.
I THINK IT IS CONSTITUTIONAL.
I THINK IT'S WHAT OUR FRAMERS
INTENDED, IT IS EVERYTHING THAT
THEY WANTED.
THIS IS A GAME OF WORDS, THIS IS
HOW EVERYONE INVOKES PRAYER, THE
CONSTITUTION, INTO TAKING IN GOD
WE TRUST OUT OF EVERY COURTROOM
IN THIS COUNTRY, TAKE PRAYER OUT
OF THE CLASSROOM BUT NOW WE HAVE
TO SAY A PRAYER FOR ALL OF THIS
BALONEY.
IT IS HOGWASH.
NONE OF THIS HAS ANY SUBSTANCE
TO IT.
AND THE FACT THAT THEY NOW WANT
TO DUST OFF THE MUELLER REPORT
BECAUSE THEY KNOW UKRAINE HAS NO
EVIDENCE, NO SUBSTANCE TO IT,
THIS IS PATHETIC.
AND WHO JUST SAID THE OTHER DAY
MY CONCERN IS IF WE DON'T
IMPEACH HIM HE WILL GET
REELECTED.
THIS IS A SAD COMMENTARY WHERE
THEY'RE TAKING AWAY THE AMERICAN
PUBLIC'S ABILITY TO VOTE FOR
PRESIDENT, AND THE FEDERALISTS,
ALEXANDER HAMILTON DESCRIBES
IMPEACHMENT AS A CRISIS, AS A
RELEASE VALVE FROM A CRISIS OF A
NATIONAL REVOLUTION.